not only is Apple working on a larger
iPad but with that a new version of iPad
OS that is going to make use of this
larger display now in this video I'm
going to give you guys all the info that
we have we had previous leaks and some
new information from a user that
actually was the first person to mention
Apple's Dynamic Island for the iPhone
back when we thought we're gonna have
two separate cutouts side by side on the
iPhones and he's been putting out new
leaks that are very credible now before
we get into the details on this new iPad
I have to mention that I am actually
even more excited for a better version
of iPad OS 17 because when Apple added
the M1 chip to the iPad we were all
finally waiting on a professional
version of iPad OS that would solve a
lot of the shortcomings even the
previous chips were just fine the
limitation was the software but
unfortunately Apple just added a few
little features and they were still
really limiting later they gave us stage
manager as a kind of fix but a lot of
people weren't super impressed with it
especially with uh the limitations and
the certain chips and iPads you couldn't
use it with it was more like an upgrade
tactic so you guys let me know what are
you more excited for a larger iPad or
just better iPad software that has a lot
more capabilities to make use of the
powerful Hardware now on to the larger
iPad some people might say why would you
want a larger iPad 12.9 inches is big
enough well there are a few reasons and
for those that are kind of doubting this
I think by the end of this video you
won't be take a look at what Apple has
been doing recently we had the iPhone 14
plus which is a cheaper version with a
larger screen that is a first and then
the upcoming 15-inch MacBook Air that is
going to be a large screen for a cheaper
price which is what a lot of people want
now all the way back in 2021 Mark German
which has a great track record said the
apple is working on larger screened
iPads but they will take a couple years
to come and here we are in 2023 and then
after that Ross young which is a display
analyst with pretty much the most
accurate record in terms of devices with
these displays coming to Market you can
literally see his record the only thing
he got wrong is the naming of the iPhone
se he confirmed that the 14.1 inch iPad
Pro is being developed with their supply
chain sources in that it will have many
LEDs and promotion as well and he gave
us a timeline of
2023 and confirming that Majin Buu
another great source said that apple is
developing a 14.1 inch iPad M2 with 512
gigs and 16 gigs of RAM as the base
storage meaning that this is going to be
a high-end device now the m two-part
that part right there is a little weird
because these this new leak says that
it's going to be an M3 based chip but of
course this product is still in the
works and it could make sense if it's
high-end that it will have the latest
chip if it was pushed back just a little
bit especially if it's gonna have those
base specs and it's going to be an
expensive device and even the iPad Air
is going to be getting the M2 so they
want it to stand apart but the weird
thing was that shortly after that he
revised his information saying that it
doesn't look to feature a mini LED or
Pro motion so this iPad that was still
being developed doesn't seem to be a pro
device that costs a lot of confusion and
it didn't make sense why would Apple
make the largest iPad ever and make it a
budget one uh one kind of thought was to
upsell those that have smaller iPads but
the people are willing to use such a a
large device it would make a lot more
sense to price it higher and have higher
end features and that's what looks like
is actually going to come latest info is
from analyst 941 who is a Twitter user
and that post on the Mac Rumors forums
telling us about the iPad Pro 14.1 inch
and giving us some info now once again
he was the guy that first brought out
the news about Apple's Dynamic Island
how the layout will be based on
information from his engineer friends
and more recently he was the one that
shared the info about the capacitive
buttons on the iPhone 15 Pro Models the
microprocessor that's gonna manage all
of this and a lot of other information
that have since been confirmed and with
that a bunch of information on iOS 17
lock screen details control center a
bunch of different updates as well so he
is very welcome connected now the first
info that he gave us was short but it
actually points to a few different
things including the M3 chip on the
upcoming MacBooks and I'll explain why
but this is what he said a 14.1 inch
iPad that supports two 6K Thunderbolt
slash usb4 displays using daisy chaining
and a date of
2024. now this makes a little bit of
sense because we also had info that the
14.1 inch iPad was canceled for 2023 and
that 2024 date also makes sense because
when Apple releases their iPads they
usually have a launch cycle about a year
and a half so that would line up say for
Springtime and the second part of that
is that special version of iPad West 17
that's being developed specifically for
larger iPads which could be called the
iPad Ultra or Studio video and the
change in there for two 6K displays at
60 hertz so that is a support in the
code He also mentioned that that signals
that it's going to have an M3 Pro uh but
not so fast I don't think so and he
actually kind of agreed that it does not
make sense because it doesn't have to
have an M3 Pro in order to have multiple
displays that are external that could
just be a fix for the M3 chip both the
M1 and M2 Chip could only support One
external display that was a limitation
but people are having enough of that
they're getting fed up so with the M3
chip it makes much more sense that that
chip itself could support two external
displays and that also gives this device
a capability like that now another
option is that this larger iPad could
have two Thunderbolt ports built in and
I say absolutely yes please if we're
getting a larger iPad with better
software that does have a high price tag
give us two ports that way you can
charge at the same time and connect
something else or connect multiple
devices and multiple displays so what do
you guys think about a larger iPad with
better software is that something that
you would spend extra money on an iPad
that is actually a laptop replacement
but with the extra added features of a
tablet you'll have a new keyboard case
that's also probably going to be
expensive Apple got a patent for that
you let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below how much would
you be willing to spend go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
foreign